die Eigentums und Besitzrechte der
betreffenden Völker an dem von ihnen von
altersherbesiedeltem Land sind
anzuerkennen
die Rechte der betroffenen Völker an den
natürlichen Ressourcen Ihres Landes sind
besonders zu schützen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
aufgepasst
gleich werde ich zu Tarzan
[Musik]
um zu wachsen muss Peru seine Märkte
ausbauen
[Musik]
wir müssen mehr in Öl und Gas
investieren
[Musik]
in Peru
amerikanische Unternehmer
ohne politische Konflikte
als Mitglied der amerikanischen
Handelskammer würde ich in Peru
investieren
natürlich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich liebe den Tunnel den Amazonas ich
kenne nichts anderes von hier komme ich
her
die Gaben der Erde schätzen
lokalisieren mit mein Vater sagte immer
wir würden uns die Erde nur leihen wir
sollten nicht einfach damit tun was wir
wollen
wer sich etwas leid muss darauf
aufpassen mehr noch als der dem es
gehört
[Musik]
wir müssen sie der nächsten Generation
in noch besserem Zustand überlassen
früher habe ich mit ihnen gespielt
hallo
darf ich die Kinder grüßen
mein Sohn heißt übersetzt Wasserfall
und du
Ureinwohner am Amazonas Folgen stets dem
Prinzip Naturschätze nicht auszubeuten
sondern sie zu respektieren
[Musik]
unser Land ist uns heilig
unser Land ist der Samen unserer
Existenz ohne das Land wären wir
verloren
ich habe im Wald ein wenig Beute gemacht
früher gab es hier viele Tiere
sie liefen am Fluss auf und ab
nichts ist mehr übrig
[Musik]
da ist die nordperoanische Ölpipeline
versunken in Wasser und Schlick
das sind die Schäden die das Öl in der
Region hinterlässt
[Musik]
das Rohöl ist bis hier oben gekommen
die Hand wird schwarz davon auch hier
unten ist viel Ruhe
im Winter treibt das Öl bis hier oben
und die Fische ernähren sich dann von
dem Pflanzen
[Musik]
die meisten Patienten leiden an
Kopfschmerzen Übelkeit und Schwindel
das liegt daran dass Auslaufen des Öl
das Wasser verschmutzt
unsere Wasser enthält viele giftige
Metalle die unserer Bevölkerung schaden
sind tot geweiht
[Musik]
die konzentrierte Ansammlung von Geld
und Wohlstand
nennen
denn man will oder nicht man tötet den
Regenwald die Kulturen ganze Völker
[Musik]
Präsident allen Garcia reiste bis
Peitsche so wo barrit oil eines der
größten Ölvorkommen des Landes fördern
will
sehr aufregend
[Musik]
das sichert die Zukunft unseres Landes
und bietet neue Chancen
die Regierung will Peru zu einem Stahl
Gas Öl und
mineralstoffexporteur machen
auf per
Präsident Garcia wollte große
Investitionen am Amazonas fördern die
Ureinwohner standen den jedoch im Weg
er ging so weit ihre Territorien als
Verschwendung zu bezeichnen die man
besser Privatunternehmen verkaufen
sollte
[Musik]
Präsident Alan Garcia reiste voller
Optimismus und mit hohen Erwartungen in
die USA um das Freihandelsabkommen zu
bewerben
ich bin sehr optimistisch
das Abkommen wird ein großer Schritt
nach vorn für unser Land sein
verabschiedete Gesetze um ein
Freihandelsabkommen mit den USA zu
schließen
einige davon betrafen alle indigenen
Bevölkerungen des Amazonas Regenwalds in
Peru
gestern
das gemeinschaftsland der indigenen
Bevölkerung abzuschaffen oder zumindest
auszuhüllen
einige Gesetze zielten darauf ab
Gemeinschaftseigentum abzuschaffen
die Gesetze gaben privaten Unternehmen
das Recht die Rohstoffe des Regenwaldes
auszubeuten auch ohne Erlaubnis oder
Absprachen mit den Eingeborenen vor Ort
die Firmen bekamen einen Blankoscheck
das Freihandelsabkommen mit den USA ist
zustande gekommen
Präsident Garcia hat es am Nachmittag
unterzeichnet
[Musik]
unverkäuflich wir verhandeln nicht über
unser Land
[Musik]
schön dich zu sehen
bist
hier habt ihr etwas Geld damit wir Gold
und Öl auf eurem Land abbauen können
das Geld reicht zwei oder drei Jahre
Moment Moment
nichts
der Fluss vergiftet das Land verpestet
nichts bleibt
nur der Tod wollt ihr das
[Musik]
warum verkauft alangasia euer Land
er sollte seines verkaufen dort Öl
fördern
wir können nicht weg
unsere Ahnen lehrten uns unser Land zu
verteidigen
unsere Großeltern und Eltern kämpften
für ihren Anspruch auf das Land
ohne das Land sind wir nichts
Konvention 169 haben wir ganz klar das
Recht über das Land unseres Volkes und
unsere Prioritäten zu entscheiden
wir haben ein Recht auf Frieden
auf ein würdiges Leben auf unserem Land
die Konvention 169 unterzeichnet diese
verpflichtet die Regierung bei Gesetzen
die die Rechte von Ureinwohnern
betreffen diese in die Beratungen mit
einzubeziehen das ist nicht geschehen
außerdem sind die Gesetze
verfassungswidrig
die Verfassung garantiert den
Ureinwohnern ihre Rechte
[Applaus]
ich bin Anführerin einer Gemeinde und
bin hier aufgewachsen
meine Eltern ernten mich mit sauberem
Wasser
frisches Essen
für den Schutz unseres Landes unseres
Wassers und unsere Luft geben
unser Anführer Alberto ist hier also
sage ich
bringen Sie unsere Botschaft zu
peruanischen Regierung
sagen Sie ihnen dass wir existieren das
auch wir Peruaner sind wir sind
Ureinwohner aber wir sind doch Peruaner
2009 beschlossen Anführer der indigenen
Völker stellvertreten für 1.350
Gemeinschaften gegen die Gesetze der
Regierung zu protestieren
[Musik]
was fordern die Ureinwohner
Gerechtigkeit die Achtung unserer Rechte
unseres Landes und unserer Traditionen
hallo ich melde mich wegen der Teilnahme
an den Protesten
wir
können mehr als vier Boote voller
Menschen bringen wahrscheinlich sogar 15
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dies ist ein friedlicher landesweiter
Protest in unseren angestammten
Territorien
wir verlangen das die Regierung die
Gesetze die gegen unsere grundlegenden
Rechte verstoßen umgehend wieder ruft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ethnische Gruppen am Amazonas streiken
sie wehren sich gegen Gesetze durch die
sie ihr Land bedroht sehen
in vier Regionen am Amazonas wird
protestiert sie warten auf die Antwort
der Regierung
von Ureinwohnern aller Zeiten
mehr als 500 Ureinwohner versammelten
sich in traditionellen Gewand um ihre
Rechte einzufordern
selbst die die Regierung ignoriert hat
wir haben hier zwei Hochburgen mit etwa
3000 Leuten aber jung und Vampir
im Kongress gibt es keine Ureinwohner
die uns vertreten nur reiche Leute die
die Interessen der transnationalen
Firmen schützen wollen
eine selbst folgt die Mandat seines
Volkes
wir sind lediglich das Sprachrohr der
Entscheidungen unserer Eingeborenen
Brüder
die Ureinwohner haben entschieden dass
die Proteste andauern werden bis die
Regierung auf unsere Forderungen eingeht
wir bitten die Regierung sich umgehend
mit uns zu treffen um bedauerliche
Konsequenzen zu vermeiden
mit Rohstoffen wie Öl Gas und Holz so
wie dem enormen Fisch Reichtum des
Amazonas können wir vielen Menschen
Arbeit geben
die durch Zufall dort geboren wurden
der Amazonas gehört euch und euren
Kindern er gehört der ganzen Nation
der Reichtum Perus gehört allen
Peruanern und sollte uns allen von
Nutzen sein Leben
[Applaus]
wir sprechen heute mit Alberto pisango
Präsident von eidesm
wie protestieren und wollen uns heute
hier erklären warum es geht
wir werden uns nicht gegen den
Fortschritt man verteufelt uns gerne
sagt wir Eingeborenen wäre nur
Unruhestifter
ein Haufen wilde die den Fortschritt
nicht verstehen darum hält man uns für
fortschrittsfeinde
das stimmt aber nicht
wir freuen uns über Fortschritt für das
Land sind aber nicht bereit dafür Leben
zu gefährden
du kannst da nicht durchgehen
die Polizei
die Gruppe steht hier und bewegt sich
nicht weg
[Musik]
aufgrund der Straßensperren der
Ureinwohner leiden tausende Menschen in
San Martin da die Grundversorgung mit
Waren und Dienstleistungen nicht
funktioniert
die Straße Villa und die Terry
in einer Machtdemonstration haben sie
auch die Hauptstraße von jurimagas
eingenommen
dadurch die Blockade die Grundversorgung
gefährdet war
ich leitete eine Kommission die sich mit
den Ureinwohnern und ihrem
Repräsentanten Alberto pisango treffen
sollte
das Treffen dauerte mehrere Tage
der Staat hat die Ureinwohner am
Amazonas jahrhundertelang vernachlässigt
die Regierung und der Präsident Garcia
wird diesen Missstand vom heutigen Tage
an beenden
wir werden die Gesetze überarbeiten und
die Teile die unsere Eingeborenen Brüder
betreffen ändern
wir werden diese spezifischen Teile
entfernen ohne dabei jedoch unserem Land
zu schaden
wir sind zuversichtlich dass wir
aufgrund der heutigen Fortschritte
dauerhafte Lösungen finden werden
Sie die spezifischen Artikel zu benennen
mit denen sie Probleme
wir fragten sie welche Artikel wir
streichen sollten
sie sagt jedoch nur abschaffen
abschaffen
es war ein produktives treffen
jedoch wurde keine Einigung erzielt
insgesamt war es eine positive
Angelegenheit wir erhoffen uns von den
kommenden Stunden konkrete Ergebnisse
mehr kann ich aktuell nicht dazu sagen
wie können wir den Änderungen zustimmen
wenn die Gesetze hinter unserem Rücken
gemacht werden ohne uns einzubeziehen
sie sind verfassungswidrig und gehören
abgeschafft
wir können keine sofortige Lösung
erwarten wenn wir ehrlich mit der
Bevölkerung Perus sein wollen
wir brauchen eine langfristige Lösung
zum Wohle unseres Landes
werden sie weiter protestieren mehr kann
ich nicht sagen morgen bekommen Sie
weitere Neuigkeiten
[Musik]
hunderte Ureinwohner mit Speeren und
Gesichtsbemalung in traditioneller
Bekleidung haben die Anlage Nummer 6 von
Pedro Peru in Loretto umzingelt
nach und nach kamen mehr und mehr
Mitglieder der Ureinwohner Gemeinden den
Fluss entlang mit Booten
sie wollten ein wichtiges Ziel einnehmen
um die Aufmerksamkeit der regieren zu
bekommen
in diesem Fall war es die Anlage Nummer
wir sprachen mit dem Leiter der Anlage
von petroperud darüber die Ölpipeline zu
schließen
wir wollten die Regierung unter Druck
setzen
dass wir das ganze Land mit Öl
versorgten
[Musik]
heute zu Gast ist der Präsident von
eidesep Alberto PI Sango guten Abend
guten Abend vielen Dank für die
Einladung und diese Gelegenheit sie
haben eine Pipeline von Pedro Peru
übernommen
sollte die Gasversorgung zusammenbrechen
gäbe es in Lima keinen Strom mehr und
die Stadt würde im Chaos versinken trotz
alledem weigern sie sich die Proteste
einzustellen
nichts davon wäre geschehen wäre die
Regierung auf die Forderungen der
Ureinwohner eingegangen
wir hatten schon Bedenken geäußert bevor
die Gesetze in Kraft traten
und was ist mit den Rechten der
eingebunden
im Stillstand verharren
[Musik]
und ihre Interessen
jedoch niemals die Grundrechte und die
Gebietsansprüche der Ureinwohner
ich bin nicht bereit im Dunkeln zu
sitzen nur weil sie nicht zu einem
Dialog bereit sind niemand in der Stadt
will das vielen Dank ich hoffe sie
zeigen in Zukunft mehr
Dialogbereitschaft
wir sind Dialog bereit das wird leider
nicht so vielen Dank
sie protestieren seit mehr als einem
Monat und es ist keine Lösung in Sicht
wenn wir mit dem Protest aufhören fragen
Sie den Präsidenten weil er die Gesetze
aufhebt dann gehen wir
mit genug politischem Willen lassen sich
alle Probleme lösen
wir bleiben hier und tragen die
Konsequenzen
diese Menschen sind keine Könige sie
sind nicht Bürger erster Klasse
400.000 Eingeborene können nicht 28
Millionen Peruanern vorschreiben sie
hätten kein Recht hierher zu kommen das
geht nicht
für uns alle eine primitivere Zeit
herbei
die Regierung war bisher sehr geduldig
aber das Land kann nicht auf Dauer mit
der Pistole an der Schläfe weitermachen
und die Ordnung wiederherstellen das
Falk erwartet Ordnung vom Staat wir
müssen ein Ende erwürgen
[Musik]
Regierung hat in vier Regionen am
Amazonas den Notstand ausgerufen
die Regierung war stets bemüht Geduld
und Toleranz walten zu lassen
diese Aufruhr ist aber untragbar und
zielt darauf ab unsere Regierung als
verwundbar und schwach darzustellen
das können wir nicht zulassen wir werden
unsere verfassungsgemäße Autorität in
vollem Maße zur Geltung bringen
ich möchte mit diesem einen Herrn
sprechen alle anderen bleiben bitte
zurück
bitte
ich führe die Polizei Spezialeinheit an
wir stimmen in ihrem Protest und ihren
Forderungen zu
können sie aber nicht unterstützen
ich muss Sie daher bitten die Brücke
friedlich zu verlassen
der Kampf gilt der Regierung
Brüder Soldaten
ihr seid nicht unser Feind
ia ist ein Verräter
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
ebenso wie der Präsident den Notstand
ausgerufen hat rufen auch wir
Eingeborenen eine Notstand in unseren
Gebieten aus
Kampfes hat entschieden unser Volk zum
Aufstand aufzurufen
daher werden wir nur noch unseren
traditionellen von unseren Vorfahren
überlieferten Gesetzen
jedes Eindringen von Streitkräften in
unsere Territorien werden wir als
Aggression von außerhalb betrachten
warum stellen Sie den Dialog mit der
Regierung ein
Ihnen den nächsten Schritt zu machen und
die Gesetze aufzuheben unsere Haltung
ist seit langem klar
Aufhebung der Gesetze oder Tod das ist
die Entscheidung des Volkes
vergessen heraus er schickt tausende
Eingeborene zum Scharfrichter
wir wollen keine Gewalt wenn die
Regierung jedoch diese Ansicht ist sehen
wir uns gezwungen den Aufstand zu
beenden
[Musik]
wir werden unseren Protest dennoch
fortführen denn das ist unser gutes
Recht
[Musik]
wir waren 38 Polizisten inklusive
Kommandant Montenegro
wir müssen mehr wir sollten bei Anlage
Nummer 6 Ruhe und Ordnung waren
38 Polizisten sind nicht genug wenn
1.500 Menschen vor den Toren stehen
[Musik]
ihre Anführer sagen uns dies ist ein
friedlicher Protest
trotz des Notstandes möchten wir ihnen
mit Respekt begegnen
[Musik]
oder schlimmeren kommen
wir sind alle Peruaner und lieben unser
Land
[Musik]
unterzeichneten eine Vereinbarung mit
der Polizei einander nicht anzugreifen
[Musik]
unsere Gegner in diesem Kampf war nur
die Regierung die Judikative und die
Legislative niemand sonst
die Proteste halten nun seit 50 Tagen an
doch das Problem ist immer noch dasselbe
werden die Gesetze nicht aufgehoben wird
weiter protestiert
[Musik]
die Exekutive keine Schritte zur Lösung
des Problems unternahm wandten wir uns
an die Parteien im Kongress
nach und nach an alle politischen
Parteien
[Musik]
ich muss um zehn vor zwölf Weg
organisiert eine Vertretung
also
dieses Dokument enthält unsere
Forderungen
besonders umstritten war gesetzt 10 90
das Forstgesetz
gemäß dem neuen Forstgesetz konnten
Teile des Regenwaldes die bisher als
gemeinschaftliche natürliche Ressource
unter Obhut des Staates gehalten in
private Hände verkauft werden
unsere Eingeborenen Brüder haben
entschieden bei Aufhebung von gesetzt
sie 90 die Proteste zu beenden
[Musik]
bei den Verhandlungen im Kongress aber
so setzte die Regierung ihre eigene
Partei unter Druck
sie sagten das schon durch die Änderung
eines einzigen Punktes oder Kommas in
diesem Gesetzen
das gesamte Freihandelsabkommen in sich
zusammenfallen würde
das war eine Lüge
im Internet das Land der Ureinwohner
hatte nichts mit dem Freihandelsabkommen
zu tun überhaupt nichts das war der
große betrug von alangasias Regierung
[Musik]
hatte die Mehrheit im Kongress und seine
Partei stürzte ihren Präsidenten wenn er
die Gesetze nicht aufheben wollte würden
sie nicht aufgehoben werden
[Musik]
am 56 Tag der Proteste gelang es der
Opposition im Kongress eine Debatte über
das Forstgesetz 10 90 anzustoßen
ich denke der Kongress unternimmt einen
sinnvollen Schritt hin zur Lösung dieses
Problems
auch wenn es nur ein Gesetz ist ja auch
bei nur einem
wir hoffen jedoch dass die anderen
fraglichen Gesetze als verfassungswidrig
anerkannt werden
der Streit um die Aufhebung des
Forstgesetzes C90 wird weitergehen
wir stimmen nun über den Antrag ab die
Debatte über dieses Gesetz auszusetzen
bis die exekutivkommission ihre
Empfehlungen zur Aufhebung oder Änderung
des Gesetzes vorstellt
ich bitte um anwesenheitsfeststellung
für die Abstimmung
die Partei von Präsident Garcia stellt
unangekündigt einen Antrag weitere
Debatten über Forstgesetz 10 90 zu
vertagen und stimmt noch bevor viele
Mitglieder der Opposition eintreffen
darüber ab
registrieren Sie sich zur Abstimmung
wir stimmen über den Antrag ab
registrieren Sie sich für die Abstimmung
die Abstimmung ist beendet
38 Stimmen dafür
21 dagegen
neun Enthaltungen der Antrag wird
angenommen fahren wir fort
sie müssen die Interessen des Volkes
[Applaus]
ich bitte um Ruhe
wir wollen eine Debatte über Ideen
[Applaus]
Sitzungsbeginn war 9.30
Gefahr die gesamte Bevölkerung hat sich
den Protest angeschlossen nicht mehr nur
die Eingeborenen alle sind beteiligt
wir wollen eine demokratische Debatte
wenn wir verlieren verlieren wir wenn
wir gewinnen gewinnen wir so
funktioniert Demokratie es gehört auf
die Agenda das Thema ist abgeschlossen
das Volk und Verzeihung bitten sie haben
uns in eine Sackgasse manövriert wir
sind bei einem anderen Thema
aber was wird passieren wenn die
Bevölkerung am Amazonas davon erfährt
entschuldigen Sie das Thema ist
abgeschlossen
natürlich das Thema ist hier
nicht jedoch am Amazonas
vielen Dank
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unser Volk hatte gehofft gesetzt sie 90
würde heute abgeschafft
wenn dem so wäre könnten wir unseren
Protest umgehend einstellen
[Musik]
sie sind tot dort hinten liegen zwei
Tote
[Musik]
wir bleiben hier wenn Sie uns töten
töten Sie uns
[Applaus]
da den gelben Hemd schieß los
wir haben viele Schwerverletzte
wir stecken mit in einem schrecklichen
Konflikt
sie schießen überall mit Tränengas um
sich
wir wissen nicht was los ist wir haben
von Toten und Verletzten erfahren aber
wir können unmöglich dorthin kommen
[Applaus]
könnte tot sein
wir werden das hier für unsere
gefallenen Kollegen zu Ende bringen
für Sie denn sie schauen nun auf uns wir
bringen es zu Ende aber niemand hört
einen Finger ohne dass ich es sage
los geht's bring mir zu Ende denkt an
unser Motto niemals aufgeben
ich verbrenne deine Kamera
Schau dem Krankenwagen nach Waffen
du Penner
sagte sagte ich habe gar nichts
er hat eine Waffe
er hat eine gestohlene Waffe er hat
damit geschossen
zwei Stunden später verlagert sich der
Konflikt von der teufelskurve in eine
nahe gelegene Stadt
[Musik]
auf Menschen
die werden dich erschießen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
los zurück geht aus dem Weg
beim Kampf an der teufelskurve werden 82
demonstrierende Eingeborene und
Zivilisten angeschossen
[Musik]
elf Polizisten sterben eine verschwindet
spurlos
9 Eingeborene Männer sterben
[Musik]
ich möchte diesen Akt verurteilen
unsere Brüder wurden ermordet
einfach erschossen
dieses Stück Papier
die Regierung hätte es zerreißen und ein
neues schreiben können die sehr sehr
doch leben sind unwiderbringlich
verloren
klavierer niemand kehrt von Tode zurück
es ist eine Schande für eine
demokratische Regierung
Haftbefehl ausgestellt worden
dennoch schuldet uns die Regierung
Rechenschaft
für all die Toten des heutigen Tages
aber was ist mit den Toten Polizisten
unser Volk hat nur seine Rechte
verteidigt
der Präsident Alan Garcia
unsere Brüder hatten sich friedlich
versammelt bis die Polizei das Feuer
eröffnete
sie war nicht bewaffnet
warum sind denn die Polizisten tot
vielen Dank
[Musik]
wir mussten
nicht die Eingeborenen sind die Opfer
sondern die Polizei
solche Ereignisse geschehen nicht durch
göttliche Fügung
dies geschah planvoll durch Aufrührer
verantwortlich
vielleicht nicht im materieller Weise
sicher jedoch intellektuell
er agierte drängte täuschte Lok und
manipulierte die Eingeborenen
indem er ihnen sagte bereits verkauft
und das Wasser privatisiert
sie müssten um ihr Leben kämpfen
die Justiz sollte ihn schnell verhaften
denn mit der Verbrecher pisango die
volle Wucht des Gesetzes zu spüren
bekommt
was sollen wir tun
[Musik]
irgendwelche Neuigkeiten wegen dem
Haftbefehl
macht die Tür auf
geh hier lang sei vorsichtig
[Musik]
hier sind die Nachrichten
hallo ich rufe aus emmasita an
was geschieht dort
wir haben bei Anlage 6 38 Polizisten und
ihren Kommandanten als Geiseln genommen
als Reaktion auf die Erschießung unserer
Brüder in baguar
[Musik]
im Radio war von einem Völkermord an der
teufelskurve die Rede das war eine
unwahre Übertreibung
die Nachricht erzählte sie
der Zaun war nicht allzu stark also
rissen sie nieder überwältigten die
Waffen und drangen
[Musik]
Brüder wir sollten einander nicht
verletzen
doch sie ignorierten ihre Anführer und
alles geriet außer Kontrolle
[Musik]
berichtet
er sagte ich rede mit ihnen dann richten
wir das alles
schlugen ihn mit Stöcken und allem
möglichen und beleidigten uns wir Hunde
würden jetzt sterben
uns alle in ein Lagerhaus
nach Stunden sagten sie zum Kommandanten
wir sollten mitkommen
stellt euch in einer Reihe auf und kommt
mit
die segeln
18 Männer mit
[Musik]
ihrer Forderungen
das polizeioberhaupt des Landes übergibt
nun die peruanische Flagge an die
Familien von Kommandant Miguel Antonia
Montenegro Castillo
ich bin dankbar dass ich so einen
wunderbaren Mann an meiner Seite hatte
er war ein guter Sohn
ein guter Bruder ein guter Vater
er war 22 Jahre lang mein wunderbarer
Ehemann
diese Moment schmerzt uns alle die würde
ich liebten so sehr
wir versprechen dir aber dass wir mit
deiner Stärke weiterleben werden
diese Blume soll ein Symbol des Friedens
für alle sein
für unsere Eingeborenen Brüder denen wir
nicht mit Hass begegnen
es geht auch los
hättet ihr meinen Mann besser gekannt
hättet ihr ihn sicher beschützt
denn mein Mann war der wundervollste
Mensch dem ihr je hättet begegnen können
ich danke dir mein Liebster
[Musik]
unser Land wurde Ziel einer Verschwörung
die uns zurückhaltend
Ideologie entstand dem 19 Jahrhundert
sie versammelten ihre Armee tief im
Regenwald im rückständigsten Teil
unserer Nation
[Musik]
wir suchen noch immer den Leichnam eines
Polizisten
[Musik]
ich glaube dass er noch lebt wenn die
Suche der Regierung nicht funktioniert
müssen Sie die Eingeborenen Fragen die
wissen wo er ist lebendig oder Tod
[Musik]
die Menschen im Regenwald wissen wie man
denkt fühlt und liebt
es ist soweit gekommen weil wir unser
Land lieben Kommunismus wie sollen wir
uns Gehör verschaffen die Regierung sagt
lass die Straßen in Ruhe das geht nicht
Garcia was soll das Volk tun wenn man
ihnen alles verweigert wir bekommen sie
sonst Aufmerksamkeit um einen Dialog zu
beginnen
es ist nicht unsere Schuld ich traurig
um die Polizisten ebenso wie um unsere
Eingeborenen Brüder aber die Polizisten
werden Helden genannt weil sie gegen
einen Feind kämpften
also wir
[Musik]
Asyl gewährt und eine sichere Ausreise
für ihn beantragen
damit wir es Sango sicher von Peru nach
Nicaragua bringen können
[Musik]
aktuell warten wir darauf dass die
peruanischen Behörden den Antrag
bearbeiten
[Musik]
können dass er politisch verfolgt hat
daher wurde ihm in Einklang mit
internationalem Recht Asyl in unserem
Land gewährt
guten Tag willkommen auf Flug 4382 nach
Managua
oder der Drahtzieher der Aufrührer und
Feigling ist geflohen
und die Beteiligten der Massaker an der
Polizei werden der Gerechtigkeit nicht
entkommen
in Peru wird Alberto pissango wegen
Rebellion Volksverhetzung Mord und
Verschwörung gegen den Staat angezeigt
bei uns im Studio Innenministerin
Mercedes caberneas die gerade von einer
Trauerfeier zu den tragischen
Ereignissen kommt
zehn weitere Polizisten wurden heute tot
aufgefunden
wir empfinden tiefste Trauer es sind
zerstörerische kriminelle Kräfte am Werk
die diese Männer dazu brachten unsere
Brüder die Polizisten abzuschlachten
sie sind Barbaren
15 Eingeborene sind tot nein ich glaube
nicht dass es so viele sind
egal wie viele es hätten gar keine sein
müssen
im Ausland glaubt man die Polizei hätte
die Eingeborenen angegriffen dass diese
ausgegrenzt und misshandelt würden
es ist aber ein politisches Problem
nicht
es geht nicht um sie es war kein Problem
dass die Polizei lösen kann es geht um
ihre Ideologie
eskalierte am Freitag
am Donnerstag beschloss der Kongress
gesetzt 10 90 nicht abzuschaffen
die Eingeborenen empfanden das als Hohn
dann schickt die Regierung die Polizei
und wirft damit ein brennende
Streichholz in das Pulverfass
[Musik]
[Applaus]
a
wieder mit den transnationalen nieder
mit der Regierung ganz sicher
vereint in unserem landesweiten Protest
manche Abgeordnete sagen das Recht
müsste sich durchsetzen und das freut
mich es unterstützen
ich frage sie glauben Sie sie hätten die
Wahrheit gepachtet
sein
sind diese Gesetze möglicherweise doch
verfassungswidrig
wir sind in Toten gegenüber in der
Pflicht
wir können nicht länger unsere
Polizisten als Kanonenfutter schicken
das Problem ist politisch
das Kabinett hat Blut an den Händen und
sollte sich auflösen
[Musik]
sie sagen wir haben Blut an den Händen
wie könnten wir es zurücknehmen
halten Sie den Mund
ich bitte um Ordnung
zu unterbrechen
die Regierung hat weder Polizisten noch
Ureinwohner ermordet
das Rechtssystem wird die Schuldigen
finden
Menschen sind gestorben ihre Regierung
ist dafür verantwortlich und wird die
Schande dieser Tode für alle Zeit tragen
müssen
die Geschichte wird hart über sie
urteilen denn all dies war vermeidbar
ich beantrage die sofortige Aufhebung
dieser Gesetze da die Regierung ihre
moralische Stellung als Dialogpartner
verloren hat
[Musik]
es ist Zeit die Geschehnisse zu erfassen
und zu verarbeiten die Fehler die
gemacht wurden aus welchen Gründen auch
immer
es ist richtig dass die Gesetze
ursprünglich ohne Mitwirkung von
Vertretern der Ureinwohner entstanden
dies geschah in der Annahme ihre
gemeinschaftsländer werden dadurch nicht
betroffen
der Premierminister hat beschlossen von
neuem zu beginnen und die Gesetze
aufzuheben einen neuen Dialog
anzustreben und neue Gesetze zu
entwerfen um unseren Amazonas zu
bewahren
Wachstum kann Spannungen hervorrufen
April ich musste erfahren dass eine zu
schnelle Modernisierung des Landes zu
Konflikten führt nothing fürchten wir
jedoch nicht den Wandel wenn er unser
Land voranbringen
uns versöhnen und von neuem beginnen
das Kabinett hat einstimmig beschlossen
die Gesetze aufzuheben
[Applaus]
nachdem ich das Problem berichtigte ich
bin nicht geflohen gegen den Widerstand
vieler baten wir den Kongress um die
Aufhebung dieser Gesetze
Verantwortung war irgendjemand musste
sich verantwortlich sein
[Applaus]
Kongress die Abstimmung wird nun beendet
66 Stimmen dafür
29 dagegen keine Enthaltungen
13 Tage nach der Eskalation in Bagua
guckt der Kongress 2 der umstrittenen
Gesetze auf darunter auch Forstgesetz 10
[Applaus]
ja
lamento mucho ich trage tiefe Trauer in
mir
diejenigen Menschen die ihr Leben
verloren sind ein Schmerz tief in meinem
Herzen
allein schon die Tatsache dass es Tote
gab
es sollte nie wieder geschehen
[Musik]
mein Haus und meine Heimat sind der
Amazonas
mein Herz und meine Gedanken sind noch
im Büro
[Musik]
die Regierung sagt man würde uns
einbeziehen aber unter der Hand machen
sie weiter Geschäfte und lassen die
Unternehmen gewähren
sie verkaufen nach wie vor den Amazonas
[Musik]
ich sehe
die Größe der Bedrohung für unsere Welt
wie schwer wir sie verseuchen
wir bringen einander um
[Musik]
die Pflanzen freuen sich gerade sehr
sie stellen ihren Durst
ich glaube solange ich lebe muss ich
etwas unternehmen
[Musik]
die Regierung will Stärke und Autorität
zeigen und mich darum verhaften lassen
auch wenn man mich einsperrt ich muss
zurück
nieder mit den unterdrücken nieder mit
den unterdrücken
lange Liebe bisongo
die Sango ist ein Mörder die Sonne ist
ein Mörder alles offizielle sie
vertreten die Gefallenen Polizisten von
Bagua dort drüben sind die Unterstützer
von pisango was halten Sie davon
und zivilisierte Menschen wie können Sie
jemanden unterstützen der zur Gewalt
aufhätzt
er ist einfach ein Gangster Boss
wie können Sie jemanden unterstützen der
zum Mord an Polizisten anstachelt
es gibt einen Haftbefehl für Alberto
pissango wegen Volksverhetzung
Entführung und Verschwörung gegen den
Staat
die Polizei ist mit einem Großaufgebot
am Flughafen
[Musik]
sie müssen weggehen
zeigen sie uns die Wahrheit
haben sie angeordnet die Polizei zu
töten was sagen Sie über die Toten
Polizisten
[Musik]
Tag nach seiner Ankunft erwirkt sein
Anwalt eine Kaution und Alberto pissango
kommt frei im drohen zwei Verfahren für
die Geschehnisse im Bagua und bei Anlage
[Musik]
die Vorwürfe wegen schwer
er
angeklagt er habe die Demonstranten
überzeugt tödliche Gewalt anzuwenden
die Vorwürfe erfordern die Höchststrafe
lebenslangehaft
so funktioniert ein repressives Regime
die Regierung nutzt das Strafrecht um
ein Hindernis zu eliminieren
ich verlange das den Mördern der
Polizisten Gerechtigkeit wiederfährt
ebenso jenen die die Eingeborenen
töteten
sie sollen sich nicht hinter der Politik
verstecken können
die Verantwortlichen müssen bestraft
werden
denn sie stehen nicht über dem Gesetz
[Musik]
unsere Anführer forderten uns nie zum
Morgen auf
sie sollten freigesprochen werden aber
es gibt viel Druck von politischen
Akteuren ein exemplian pisango und den
anderen zu statuieren und so zukünftige
Proteste zu unterdrücken
du wirst lange weg
wenn du die rechte deiner Brüder
verteidigt hast
ich freue mich dass Du wieder hier bist
ich mache mir wegen deiner Situation
große Sorgen bete in deinem Namen zu
Gott
warten Sie hier
live in drei Sekunden
am 5 juni 2009 starben über 30 Menschen
bei der Konfrontation im baguar
majorbasant wurde nie gefunden
sein Vater sucht noch immer nach ihm und
ist heute unser Gast
hallo Senior Basan
danke für die Einladung
es gab zwei Fotos von Eingeborenen die
meinen Sohn mit Namen er lebte also noch
was sagt Ihnen das Bild
dass sie ihn in eine ureinwohnergemeinde
gebracht haben als sein Vater glaube ich
dass mein Sohn noch lebt denn ich habe
noch keine Beweis für seinen Tod gesehen
viele Väter haben ihre Söhne verloren
sie könnten sie aber begraben
und ihren Schmerz herauszulassen
ich muss weitersuchen bis Gott mir hilft
meinen Sohn zu finden sonst hat mein
Leben keinen Sinn
hallo wie geht's
freut mich Sie kennenzulernen
ich will ehrlich sein
das Geschehnis des geschehen aber als
Vater leide ich immer noch an den Folgen
ich suche meinen Sohn sie sind auch ein
Vater richtig ja
ich würde Ihnen empfehlen es nicht
länger in Form von öffentlicher
Strafverfolgung weiter zu betreiben
wir müssen Vertrauen bei unseren Brüdern
aufbauen
wir müssen Ihnen zusichern dass sie
nichts zu befürchten haben das ist keine
Vergeltung geben wird
ich möchte nicht mit der Polizei
Arbeiten ich weiß dass das zu nichts
wird was geschehen ist da fürchterlich
die Menschen hatten Angst
was ich will sind Informationen Senior
Alberto ich glaube er ist noch in einer
ihrer Gemeinden
ich werde oft gefragt warum ich es tue
ich weiß es nicht wenn wir seine Leiche
finden haben wir in wenigstens gefunden
schon ein einziger Knochen würde mir
inneren Frieden geben
[Musik]
die Angeklagten sollen sich bitte hier
ausweisen
[Musik]
dieses Verfahren betrifft die Ereignisse
des 9 April 2019
protestierten und forderten dass die
Regierung mehrere Gesetze aufhebe die
ihnen zufolge ihre Interessen betrafen
im Zusammenhang damit wurden Polizisten
ermordet es gab verletzte und
Sachbeschädigungen
wir werden zeigen dass der Angeklagte
die Protestierenden zu diesen Verbrechen
anstachelte
[Musik]
der erste Anklagepunkt lautet Mord
aufgrund der Tötung von Polizisten
angeklagt sind Alberto pissango
Joel ist
und Santiago manuin als Drahtzieher
dieses Verbrechens
ich war Teil des
Untersuchungsausschusses hier sind
unsere Ergebnisse
dann töteten sie die anderen Polizisten
warum töteten sie ihn nicht
das frage ich mich auch
der die Befehle gab der Kommandant sie
wollten ihn als Geisel nehmen
aber als sie zur Straße kamen war die
Menschenmenge dazu groß und außer
Kontrolle
sie hatten
ihn mit zum Fluss und zerstückelten dort
seine Leichnamen
dann warfen sie die Teile in den Fluss
Ende eine Organisation
die dem Willen ihres Volkes folgt
unter keinen Umständen und zu keiner
Zeit
unterstützen wir jemals die Anwendung
von Gewalt
napolizistin wiesen sie die Ureinwohner
an Straßen zu blockieren
nein auf keinen Fall ich folgte nur
meiner Pflicht das Anliegen meines
Volkes an die Regierung heranzutragen
wiesen sie die Eingeborenen Ansicht der
Polizei zu widersetzen ihre Position auf
der Straße zu verteidigen
an tödliche Gewalt gegen Polizisten
auszuüben
ich möchte Ihnen vielmehr die Sichtweise
meines Volkes näher bringen ich bin vom
Volk der Campo piafi unser Prinzip ist
der Schutz allen Lebens
wir können nicht töten
unsere Philosophie gestattet nicht
einmal das Töten eine Ameise denn auch
sie hat das Recht zu leben
diesen Prinzip folgend habe ich als
Präsident von alte Sepp niemals zur
Nutzung von Gewalt aufgefordert oder
aufgerufenlos
[Musik]
das bescheidene Volk jene die für ihr
Land arbeiten
wir klagen 23 tote warum
macht Hungers der Regierung
weil sie den Reichtum des Amazonas San
fremde Länder verkaufen wollen ein
bisschen private Unternehmen und die
Regierung bereichern sich und das ist
der Preis
was ist los mit dieser Welt in der Öl
oder ein Stück Gold mehr wert ist als
ein Menschenleben
[Musik]
das ist der Staatsgebiet Perus eines der
wenigen Gebiete der Welt die noch kaum
erforscht sind
dies ist gerade erst der Anfang der
möglichen Entdeckungen die Spitze des
Eisbergs
in vielen Gebieten wurde noch nicht
geboren und für weite Teile des Landes
gibt es noch keine Lizenzen
wurden aufgehoben doch die Projekte
schreiten fort auch die Abschaffung der
Gesetze konnte die Entwicklung am
Amazonas nicht aufhalten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo Alberto
[Musik]
die Welt ist im Wandel
die Gier jede einzelne natürliche
Ressource auszubeuten macht die
Menschheit blind
unsere Anführer Alberto
bei uns
[Musik]
die eingeborenen Völker kämpfen um unser
Überleben
wir werden kämpfen damit die Menschheit
immer einen Regenwald haben wird
unsere Gemeinschaft unser Volk
wir sind die Beschützer der natürlichen
Rohstoffe
zu Hause
Bandit
keine Regierung
unsere Heimat kommen
und unser Land zerstören können
[Applaus]
[Musik]
seit Alan Garcia 2011 aus dem amtschied
er ließ die peruanische Regierung neue
Gesetze zur Förderung der
Rohstoffindustrie
Eingeborene und Umweltschützer halten
diese Gesetze weiterhin für eine Gefahr
für die Rechte der Eingeborenen und den
Umweltschutz
trotz der Zusage der Regierung die
Abholzung bis 2021 einzustellen nahm die
Rodung des peruanischen Amazonas weiter
zu
2016 wurden Alberto pizango und 52
andere Eingeborene im Fall Bagua
freigesprochen noch bevor die
Verhandlung zu Anlage 6 für ihn und 26
andere begonnen hatte kein
Regierungsvertreter wurde angeklagt
alangasia lehnte mehrere
Interviewanfragen für diesen Film ab
[Musik]